back in the Golden Age of comic books
nobody probably thought twice about a
character sexuality but times change and
audiences want to find more ways to
relate to the stories they consume
readers want to know that superheroes
don't discriminate and creators have
responded throughout the years here are
a few superheroes who aren't afraid to
be themselves Ice Man when the x-men
were first introduced in 1963 the team
consisted of Cyclops beast angel Marvel
Girl and Iceman over the years
iseman evolves a number of different
looks and even had a few relationships
but it wasn't until a storyline in 2015
when a time-displaced
teenage version of Iceman was introduced
that psychic Jean Grey discovered he was
gay since the Iceman Woodall been
reading since the 1960s never indicated
this was the case except maybe once the
characters had a talk it was revealed
that Iceman couldn't cope with being
both a mutant and gay but since he had
to deal with his powers openly he
suppressed his own sexuality to the
point where he refused to even think
about it after talking with his teen
self Iceman was able to come to terms
with his feelings and the character is
now openly gay North Star the Canadian
mutant known as North Star is a member
of Alpha Flight and has had numerous
appearances and the x-men comics over
the years he's also Marvel's first
openly gay character in fact an issue 51
of astonishing x-men North Star marries
his husband though not as popular as the
x-men alpha flight with a team of
mutants who operated north of the border
in Canada North Star serves as an
integral member of the team and has a
variety of powers including superhuman
speed flights and the ability to fire
photonic blasts of energy he and the
rest of the team were created by
legendary writer John Byrne in 1983 who
at first didn't want to create the team
as two-dimensional nobodies to counter
the x-men in order to alleviate his own
misgivings he created more fleshed out
backgrounds for the characters which
included making North Star a gay
character
unfortunately north-south sexual
orientation could only be hinted at for
years since editorial policy at the time
forbade characters from being homosexual
but a woman you are probably familiar
with Batgirl the alter-ego of Barbara
Gordon
the buzz woman actually predates her by
a few years she was introduced in the
mid 1950s or the love interest to Batman
in order to counter rumors that Batman
was gay seduction of the innocent a book
written by psychiatrist Frederic wertham
had called comics into question for
their influence over children and in
particular called out the characters of
Batman and Robin suggesting their
relationship was a homosexual one but
woman ended up being adds to the
character midway through the 1960s only
to be resurrected again in 2006 this
time he was given a new twist and was
reintroduced as a gay character herself
in an effort on DC's part offer more
diverse characters for their readers
Richter introduced in the late 1980s
ripped a media swathe through a number
of X titles including x-factor and
x-force as well as the New Mutants his
mutant power involves generating seismic
energy which is basically directing
earthquakes at stuff in 2009 Richter
shared a kiss with fellow x-force member
shutter star the first ever in a Marvel
comic book since that time the character
has been an open an alt-j man the
relationship between Richter and Chateau
Starr proved to be so popular and well
done
that writer Peter David won a GLAAD
award for the portrayal of their
relationship in the pages of X Factor
grey Malkin even casual Marvel fans may
have heard the word grey Malkin pop-up
now and then it's the name of the street
where Xavier school for gifted
youngsters was built as well as the name
of cable space station and since 2008
grey Malkin has also been a mutant with
the young x-men how would he get his
name his family owned the land on which
Xavier school was built and the street
was named after him as it turns out
though the character is over 200 years
old
and was caused by his father as a teen
experimenting with another boy enraged
his father beat him unconscious and
actually buried him alive on the lands I
would one day become Xavier school
fortunately for grey Malkin his mutant
powers activated and saved him from
death putting him in a kind of
hibernation until the presence when he
was freed and eventually became a member
of the young x-men I know one of the new
x-men an old mutation is a number of
lizard-like abilities to match his scaly
appearance in
losing the ability to crawl up walls a
prehensile tongue and adaptive
camouflage the character was introduced
with hints that he might be gay
given his closeness to his mentor no sir
it was later confirmed as a real deal by
the comics writers another since been
praised for being openly gay while not
making every storyline revolve around
that particular aspect of his life he's
gay but he's also a superhero so he does
superhero things aren't affected by his
sexuality in other words despite looking
like a lizard he's just a normal guy
Angela one of the coolest characters in
recent comics history angela was
originally created by Neil Gaiman and
Todd McFarlane to be part of Image
Comics spawn universe however after a
lawsuit over rights a court order that
Angela should revert fully to Gaiman who
has since sold the character to Marvel
Angela was originally a warrior from
heaven sent to fight the he'll spawn
once she joined the Marvel Universe she
ended up with the guardians of the
galaxy of all people until she has to
run off with Odin's baby to protect her
after finding out she too is an
Asgardian and the daughter of Odin
accompanying her with Sara her companion
friend and lover Deadpool Deadpool has
played straight in his movie but writers
and the man in red himself Ryan Reynolds
have openly acknowledged mr. Paul
there's actually a lot more fluid in his
sexuality than that Reynolds described
Deadpool as pansexual but don't take her
from him he is Deadpool co-creator
Fabian Nicieza explaining the Mercs
sexuality he can be heterosexual one day
and a few days later he can believe a
hundred percent that he's not Deadpool
is ready to have fun with anyone from
moment to moment
Reynolds has gone on record saying he
loves this aspect of the character and
hopes that in the sequel the current sir
could have a boyfriend just because it's
another way Deadpool breaks the
boundaries of traditional superhero
roles thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love seeing
you